what the Central Bank digital currency
is all about is surveilling Americans
and controlling behavior of Americans
today I'm here to call on the
legislature to pass legislation to
expressly forbid the use of cbdc as
money within Florida's Uniform
Commercial Code let's not assume
everyone knows what a cbdc is so just
briefly explain why that what that is
why you think it's a problem and why
you're approving of what DeSantis is
doing here
well so so what's the cbdc is CBC stands
for Central Bank digital currency and uh
you know to first order it is something
that's a lot like Bitcoin or ethereum
but it is run by Central Bank and so
every dollar can be tracked in the
ecosystem it's more programmable
um and that's different than how the
current banking system is set up where
uh you know without getting too
technical it's more opaque it's all
spread out across different databases as
opposed to like one Consolidated
database where you can track literally
every single dollar moving everywhere
right so from a technology standpoint
the cbdc is an efficiency and
transparency and programmability
improvement over you know the status quo
if that was if you're living in a high
trust Society you might be able to do
that right the problem is we're not in a
Hydra Society unfortunately or in a
society where these genuine productivity
gain unfortunately will come with a with
a hook it's like uh it was like a sweet
you know where it's got a a hook in the
bait and the the hook is total
surveillance total control
um building freeze account drain
accounts in fact the euphemism of
consumer to government payments if you
take the observation that for example uh
you know DeSantis has come out against
CBC he's also got a Florida State yard
like he's making you know make America
States again right
Federalism is on the rise and uh you
know for the last 10 years or so states
have been breaking away from the feds
both left and right on not just
Sanctuary cities of course but on gun
laws drug laws abortion laws crypto
everything right and crypto in
particular uh you know you have for
example Texas says the right to buy sell
Sin receive Bitcoin shall not be
infringed Wyoming and Tennessee have the
Dow laws uh Mississippi and Montana have
Bitcoin mining protection acts the
Florida mayor uh accepts the salary of
Bitcoin Colorado accepts taxes Bitcoin
New Hampshire's friendly to
cryptocurrency okay so
um what I anticipate is that this is
going to become a major political issue
but not in the typical left right way
more of a federal versus States issue
with
um more and more States potentially
doing something like reopening gold
window here's a preview of an article
I'm writing okay reopening the gold
window except it's a digital gold window
so we have bitcoin.florida.gov
bitcoin.texas.gov
bitcoin.wyoming.gov okay and so on and
what you can do is it's a simple Bitcoin
exchange where you can buy and sell
Bitcoin either as a brokerage or just by
placing limit orders and these order
books
um they can use you know commercial
exchanges or they can peer with each
other okay and the state takes a cut of
this
and they are able to start holding up
their digital gold reserves like they'll
sell them and they have restored the
intra convertibility into digital gold
that essentially reverses what Nixon did
in 1971 okay and why do they do this
well uh the scientists actually put out
some stuff on how he might actually have
state chartered Banks
um banking crypto uh as a response to
the FED trying to shut off uh banking
access to crypto at which point if you
game it out essentially if you want your
daily to shut off fed wire or ACH or
other access to State Charter Banks
which would mean like cutting off
Florida simply to cut off crypto which
is probably too big a thing and If the
Fed did it it would actually show the
financial totalitarianism that she's
saying is potentially there with the
CNBC if they didn't do it well then they
have to actually allow the currency of
the People by the people for the people
to not perish from this earth right we
have actually have a Bitcoin exchange
that is now at a government level right
and so the thing is you know you're
seeing the movie Pacific Rim
sure yes yeah so Pacific Rim it's like
these giant monsters come out of the
ocean and humans cannot fight those
giant monsters so you have to build
giant rods okay so when when you've got
a comp when you've got a government that
is attacking companies you can't beat a
government with a company you can only
beat it with another government
okay so Florida or Texas has enough hit
points
to be a giant robot that can stand up to
harassment from the federal government
and I think that's what's going to come
yeah I uh I favor separation of church
and state and I separation favor
separation of Bitcoin and state and all
other cryptocurrencies in state so I'm
not keen on state governments running
exchanges those should be in private
hands they should play hands off toward
private exchanges and let them do their
thing and so of course should the
federal government
so I mean that's what I think we have to
rely on to uh
yeah preserve our monetary freedom of
choice we have to be eternally Vigilant
against encroachment of our uh rights
and our liberties by the federal
government and by the state governments
yeah I I do actually understand that
view
um but that's also why I I wouldn't call
myself an orthodox libertarian at all uh
you know like you know Lee Kuan Yew was
pretty much all over the political map
and did what what he thought was best
for the country at any one time like you
know whether it was subsidizing houses
or doing things that seemed to be for
the left or the libertarian right or
what have you he he did some combination
of policies idiosyncratic heterodox
combination policies and um and I don't
think that you can beat government
harassment
with just lawsuits
um I think like basically you need
another state to kind of be on the other
side of that uh and I think that's
what's going to happen
so
um
look at his unilateral disarmament uh if
you are if if one is not actually taking
through Bitcoin really means seriously
um it means essentially the currency of
a free people that you're not monitored
you can't be you can't have your savings
you know stolen and Frozen right but
that that has an interaction go ahead
and that's why I'm not a fan of what's
happened in El Salvador where the
government has tried to mandate that
businesses accept Bitcoin whether they
want to or not fortunately it hasn't
taken
have refused it and it's been
unenforceable
I I completely understand where you're
coming from in fact there is a
difference of opinion in the community
on this sure
um but ultimately there's actually a
higher sort of standard which is is El
Salvador going to attract migrants on
net
right did it say if there is a seeming
violation of one or the other
libertarian principle but they preserve
the freedom to exit and other people are
able to exit there and if they're
choosing that jurisdiction or brothers
remember local trade-offs they make that
may be
um you know like incorrect by by one
Theory or another are
um
nevertheless something that on balance
attracts people
right and I think there's actually
multiple solutions to that that is to
say for example uh the Netherlands has a
very liberal drug policy Singapore has a
very strict drug policy but arguably
they're both better than the US has this
bizarre you know bipolar cash and
release type policy where it's
simultaneously very harsh punishments
and non-punishments you know so we're a
Singapore not only very clear about
their their goals hey thanks for
watching and excerpt from that
conversation with Balaji srinivasan and
Lawrence H white about balaji's million
dollar Bitcoin bet the state of the
banking system and the US dollar you
could watch the full conversation here
or another clip here